please welcome our friend Joel McHale
[Applause]
[Music]
they're caring each other apart for that
okay you just threw your hardcover book
yeah hard into the audience yeah just
something mom know that guy okay are you
alright you can't be whipping things
around by the pregnant lady hey Conan I
don't care about people
oh yeah I didn't know that yeah this is
a very attractive audience so losing one
would be okay I've never seen anyone
whip a heart I would love to do that
favor like everyone's getting one but
you're not so that one guy you look
under your seat cuz there's nothing
there that's the magic of this show we
are cheap so let's talk for so great to
be back here with you oh you do that
came off just as you practiced it yes I
had a lot of insults to follow it yeah
yeah I know
okay I'm sorry you've let yourself go oh
yeah hey something like that I don't
know yeah I know he doesn't mean it
we're old pals he and I go way back
because our first time meeting yeah
let's talk first the book first of all
congratulations there's some really
funny stuff in here thanks for the money
thank you great Christmas holiday every
anything you sell or I'll just put it
out there wait and get it cheaper much
later on
all right you know not just anything
like you wait a while I'll hit her on
Kindle and then it sucks why haven't you
made a book what who wants to read what
I've got to say I'm out here every night
[Applause]
hey would you don't you wouldn't have to
go to Singapore or all those other
places cuz you they give you so much
money
yeah what isn't it for the book okay
there's so much dirt it is true I have
so much dirt ah Jeff do I have a lot of
dirt if I wrote a book I've got so much
crazy turd you see on many TV Jeff
actually listen to that question now I
asked him am i gay
oh yeah you're gay oh yeah I can tell
you again the book first of all you made
a choice yes you go with your picture of
you on the cover that's yes colour is
it's the brightest book I've seen quite
a while thank you for saying that
because when they asked about the design
they were like what would you like to
look like and I was like call NASA and
asked for the brightest color ever made
and cuz if it's true yes and I they
didn't call NASA cuz they didn't they
really didn't want it but uh I was like
I want it to be obnoxious and loud so if
it's in an airport people will go oh not
Anna Kendrick not her not her ah that
douche bag
yeah and so hopefully it worked there
was one color they were going to use but
it makes you it makes your ears bleed so
this is one step below that yeah this is
a pretty eye catching
you